hausverbot im weißen haus für donald
trump es liegt am amtierenden
präsidenten ob er freiwillig geht oder
vor die tür gesetzt wird am 20 januar
punkt 12 so sieht es die us verfassung
vor wird trump es wagen die demokratie
in den usa vorzuführen oder geht da noch
was vor den gerichten nach der us-wahl
wand gibt jump auf jetzt in der phoenix
runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer meine gäste
zunächst hier im studio immer druck ist
bei uns cdu-politiker ehemaliger
vorsitzender des auswärtigen ausschusses
im europäischen parlament zeitweise
zeitgleich mit dem vorsitzenden des
ausschusses im amerikanischen senat das
war damals schon bei den kannten sie
oder kennen sie aus dieser zeit gute
sind auch begegnet als er schon
vizepräsident war also ein beiden kennen
ihre kirschbaum ist freier journalist
hierfür us medien in deutschland und
zugeschaltet ist uns dritter waldschmidt
nelson professorin für die geschichte
des europäisch transatlantischen
kulturraums in augsburg und schließlich
mein kollege jan philipp burkhardt aus
dem ard-studio in washington dort
korrespondent für die usa hamburg hat
wie ist denn im moment der stand der
dinge in den usa hoffen da die trump
anhänger nach den alternativen fakten
der letzten vier jahre jetzt auf ein
alternatives wahlergebnis also zumindest
die trump anhänger mit denen ich so in
den vergangenen tagen gesprochen habe
hoffen auf ein alternatives wahlergebnis
die sind sehr optimistisch dass trump
noch vor den gerichten erfolg haben kann
und sie sagen schon jetzt dass sie einen
neuen präsidenten beiden überhaupt nicht
anerkennen würden
also dieser kampf um die öffentliche
meinung der ja über den juristischen
kampf hinaus geht sozusagen erscheint
durchaus früchte zu tragen
herr brok niederlagen im wahlkampf
einzugestehen das gilt ja in einer
demokratie als besonders ehrenhafte joe
biden hat jetzt von peinlichkeiten
gesprochen über das verhalten von donald
trump warum tut sich der amtierende
präsident so schwer
ich glaube das licht in seiner
persönlichkeit er kann nicht verstehen
dass er verlieren kann
das ist das nazistische deswegen jemand
wie er kann nicht verlieren hat das ist
glaube ich das entscheidende für ihn und
es nachher hier mit allen
möglichkeiten versucht im amt zu bleiben
da gibt es natürlich auch angerichtet
die sagt er verliert die immunität das
könnte für ihn problematisch werden das
dann klagen gegen hinkommt manche sagen
sogar dass sein unternehmen auf so
schwachen füßen gestellt ist das dann
doch die kreditwürdigkeit leiden würde
so dass das doch ein sehr tief
greifender kampfes trump ist kein
normaler politiker der weist das in der
demokratie siegen und niederlage auf
geht mal zu trifft also weniger ein
politischer als ein unternehmerischer
ansatz frau waldschmidt nelson bevor ich
die frage stelle schauen wir uns mal die
beiden treats an die donald trump heute
noch abgesetzt hat wir werden gewinnen
wir werden siegen der eine und der
andere fast noch aufschlussreicher wir
machen große fortschritte
nächste woche kommen die resultate
möglicherweise korrigierte
wahlergebnisse im sinne von trump
diamant oder entsprechende
gerichtsurteile und wir machen damit
amerika wieder groß raus mit nelson hat
donald trump tatsächlich noch auf dem
rechtsweg eine chance könnten seine
anwälte da noch irgendwo ein schlupfloch
finden was meinen sie also ich gehe
davon aus so lange er und seine anwälte
und sein team nicht in der lage sind
handfeste beweise vorzulegen für diesen
vorwurf der wahlfälschung hat er keine
chance weil kein gericht auch richter
die von ihm ernannt worden sind würde
gegen die vorliegende faktenlage
entscheiden dass dieses wahlergebnis
irgendwie gefälscht ist dass er trotzdem
behauptet alles wird gut das entspricht
ja nur seiner logik die in den letzten
monaten und jahren schon immer
verbreitet hat dass er nämlich die
wahrheit nicht unbedingt in den weg von
seinen wunschvorstellungen kommen lässt
das was trump da seit dem dritten
november auf führt das kommt ja fast an
dem shakespeare-drama gleich wie weit
werden denn bei diesem drama seine
anhänger mit gehen
das ist eine sehr spannende frage ich
glaube die tatsache dass er 71 millionen
stimmen hatten die zeit die zweitgrößte
stimmzahl aller zeiten
das ist das ist ein neue geschichte hier
und ich glaube diese anhänger ist so ein
ein kunde so ein gesuch ein gewicht das
ist wirklich nicht vorher weiß was mich
so überrascht ist dass die antiken
publikum im großen ganzen wie wirken
freiheiten mit kanal heute hat ihnen
unterstützung signalisiert zumindest
kein wollte dass er gehen soll das hat
mich überrascht ich habe gedacht und
ersten tagen ein republikaner nach dem
anderen würden sagen jetzt ist spiel um
george bush hat das gemacht bisher
eigentlich das ist für mich aber der
prominente us amerikaner ich meine ich
amerika ist der der kanzel niederlage
eingestehen spielens aus es gibt
gewinner und verlierer und tom hat
schwierigkeiten wie sie sagen mit das
wollt nieder niederlage aber es ist
deprimierend peinlichen der premiere und
konnte der mehrheitsführer im senat
einer seiner engsten mitstreiter ja
gesagt er hätte jedes recht das gericht
überprüfen lassen
dem kann man ja zunächst mal nicht
widersprechen klagen kann man gegen
alles ist das aber auch schon so ein
halbes rückzugsgefecht dass er
vielleicht antritt dieser äußerung ja
aber gibt es so viele spielwaren
forgeard und bekannte hat vor ein paar
tagen ein bisschen merkels nahegelegt
irgendwie das trump gehen sollte aber
man spürt dass diese 71 millionen
stimmen die chance bekommen hat alle
haben angst davor aber angst vor job
vielleicht mache eine neue tv sendung
vielleicht ist er in vier jahren noch
der kandidat hat irgendwie noch
unheimlich viel macht frei war willi jan
philipp burkhardt der amtsinhaber polter
jetzt es gibt nur wenige republikaner
die ihm bisher gesagt haben wir gehen da
auf die einzelnen personen noch ein
stabiler bush war ja einer die gesagt
haben gesteht eine niederlage ein
die meisten schweigen eigentlich oder
drücken sich kryptisch aus warum diese
zurückhaltung hat man wirklich angst vor
trump in der republikanischen partei
ja es ist so wäre kirschbaum sagt die
kongress abgeordneten und senatoren
haben glaube ich angst um ihre eigene
existenz denn ein einziger tweet von
donald trump könnte ja ausreichen damit
sie ihre wahl verlieren beim nächsten
mal
diese 71 millionen wähler von donald
trump die sind allen allgegenwärtig und
man möchte sich da einfach nicht
verbrennen und man weiß nicht ob trump
in vier jahren noch einmal antritt
insofern hat er einfach immer noch eine
sehr große macht sehr großen einfluss
auf diese parteibasis und so ist
wahrscheinlich dieses vornehme schweigen
der republikaner im kongress zu erklären
der burgart könnte man vielleicht sogar
sagen dass sich die republikanische
partei trump ausgeliefert hat trump hat
sich die partei in den vergangenen vier
jahren untertan gemacht das ist ja eine
der großen überraschungen auch seiner
vierjährigen amtszeit am anfang dachte
man ja dass die partei und der ganze
apparat ihn ein wenig einhegen könnte
aber das gegenteil ist passiert
donald trump hat sich diese partei zu
seinem spielball gemacht und jemand wie
mitch mcconnell der ja schon qua amt
sehr mächtig ist ist sozusagen sein
erfüllungsgehilfe geworden endlich
übrigens auch wieder justizminister war
der ja heute ein schreiben
veröffentlicht hat indem er
staatsanwälte ermächtigt schon jetzt zu
ermitteln den einzelnen bundesstaaten
obwohl das wahlergebnis offiziell noch
gar nicht vorliegt also da sieht man
einfach dass jeder namhafte republikaner
moment noch nachts rumsfeld angst davor
mit nelson jetzt hört man ja immer
wieder möglicherweise erhält er sich
eine erneute kandidatur 2024 offen das
geht ja nach der us verfassung hat ja
bis es eine amtszeit hinter sich dann
wird er so alt sein wie jetzt arbeiten
alt ist halten sie das für eine
realistische perspektive für donald
trump glauben sie dass er das wirklich
im schilde führt
ich weiß es nicht genau also dieses
gerücht wird kolportiert aus dem weißen
haus und einige seiner mitarbeiter haben
das gesagt aber ich könnte mir
vorstellen dass sollte er jetzt
tatsächlich so weit kommen dass er seine
wahlniederlage eingestehen dass er sich
irgendwie sein eigenes medium imperium
so aller rupert murdoch aufbaut in
florida und dadurch macht aufbaut denn
im grunde schlägt sein herz glaube ich
auch wirklich fürs showbusiness und ich
könnte mir vorstellen dass er jetzt nach
dieser niederlage vielleicht dann
einfach auch die nase voll hat von
diesem politbetrieb wo man dauernd auf
andere und auf die öffentliche meinung
rücksicht nehmen muss
also ich persönlich halte es für
unwahrscheinlich dass donald trump jahr
1924 nochmal antreten wird
joe biden kommen wir zu dem anderen der
beiden kontrahenten ist vielleicht jetzt
auch nicht der allergrößte glückspilz
denn er muss ja möglicherweise gegen
einen senat regieren also mit
durchregieren ist da nicht das war der
obama schon das leben schwer gemacht
wenn es so kommt wie weit lassen sich
denn dann auch von ihm angekündigte
änderungen überhaupt durchsetzen
vieles auch außenpolitisches als
politisches kann er auch als präsident
oder mit exekutivorder machen und zum
zweiten ist es so die mehrheit der
demokraten im kongress wird
wahrscheinlich sehr gering sein ist
sogar noch theoretisch wenn in georgia
nach gewählt ist das sogar gleichstand
entsteht und dann hat die vize
präsidentin die entscheidende stimme
aber ich glaube es kommt nicht dazu aber
robin war lange zeit senator der kind
das spiel des senats das trend nicht
garantiert was obama obwohl da war nur
sehr kurz die nato nicht kannte unter
viele fehler gemacht hat der wird das
eine ganz anderen art und weise
kollegial spielen wie das in letzter
zeit nicht mehr üblich war so dass ich
durchaus vorstellen kann dass es dabei
themen gibt die die dinge voranbringen
werden und außerdem könnte das ein
schutz für ihn seien die linken bernie
sanders und andere werden
zurückgehalten werden weil joe biden
sagen kann das was ihr ganz linken in
der demokratischen partei wollt das kann
ich ja da in diesem kreise nach nicht
durchsetzen
insofern ist das ein schutzzaun für ihn
innerhalb der demokratischen partei sie
haben die wahl in georgia angesprochen
da werden ja auch immer noch zur us
präsidentschaftswahl stimmen ausgezählt
da gibt es noch kein endergebnis
wahrscheinlich hat das ja auch arbeiten
gewonnen da ist aber noch viel
interessanter da zwei senatoren noch in
die stichwahl müssen jeweils ein
demokrat gegen eine republikaner
bestenfalls ein patt im senat elmar brok
hat gerade gesagt dann hätte kammerherr
ist die stimme als vize-präsidentin und
präsidentin des senats aber trotzdem um
sicher zu sein bräuchte ja joe biden
größere unterstützung da gibt es jetzt
einen republikanischen politiker name
ist mitt romney der im senat ist der
schon signalisiert er wird den beiden
unterstützen gibt es da vielleicht noch
mehr abtrünnige die sagen jetzt reicht's
vier jahre trump wir müssen da irgendwie
zu neuen ufern kommen kann sein aber es
gibt republikanische senatoren oder auch
in alaska die auch mit den demokraten
manchmal stimmen kann sein aber er hat
der block hat recht dass biden war 36
jahre senator der kann der kann sich
auch mit den republikaner in senat und
wie bill clinton bürgerin bronze
erfolgreich aus für mittlere ems in
aarberg obame weniger barack obama hat
irgendwie nicht den draht gefunden
zu den republikanischen beherrschte
senat und man kann nur hoffen dass
beiden das kann aber manche leute sagen
der ist alles nicht mehr so ist nicht
mehr möglich
in so einem polarisierten land brücken
zu bauen und in dem star das feld sind
spannend und deswegen viele demokraten
hoffen hoffen und hoffen und hoffen dass
die zwei sitze in georgia im januar noch
gewonnen werden kann dann dann hat man
50 50 und es hat aber gar nicht sicher
beiden jetzt immer wieder sagt er will
brücken bauen er ist für die amerikaner
da die ihn gewählt haben ebenso wie für
die amerikaner die ihn nicht gewählt
haben das sagen ja präsidenten
normalerweise nach der wahl auch von
donald trump hätte man solche äußerungen
gehört aber dieses brücken bauen dieses
land wieder einen diese spaltung
überwinden ist das nicht ein sie haben
sich schon angedeutet wie es in den usa
immer mit aussieht ein für eine
vierjährige amtszeit nahezu hilflos
unterfangen
ja es ist immer schlimmer ihre stärke
gewonnen des landes polarisierte alle
vier jahren wird es noch schlimmer man
kann nur hoffen dass der kanal dass die
dass die sich vereinen können dass die
was schaffen dass die gesetze
durchkriegen dass das land funktioniert
ich mein ganz erlich und ram gab es auch
wenig ge wenige sätze die erfolgreich
waren diese steuerreform war eine große
nummer aber die republikaner haben die
mehrheit im kongress gehabt die können
schon mal dieses gesetz gegen obama
durchkriegen des landes ist wirklich
sehr sehr gespalten und das sieht man
auch im kongress ich hoffe dass beiden
erfolg haben kann mit ein szenario für
publica nisch gefühlt oder demokratisch
das kann man also man kann nur hoffen
dass die zwei wenn ich viel gute jahren
haben und viele reformen auf den weg
bringen das land braucht bevor man das
plant braucht
mit krone man brauch mit
infrastrukturprojekte es gibt viel zu
tun und die immer gewohnt dass der
kongress funktioniert philipp burkhardt
könnte es sein dass das system drum er
von innen erodiert bei den drums
schranke der haussegen schief zu hängen
seine ehefrau und sein schwiegersohn
jared kushner haben ihm ja
offensichtlich geraten die niederlage
einzugestehen seine beiden erwachsenen
söhne eric und donald china haben zum
widerstand aufgerufen dort schüler hat
sogar zum totalen krieg gegen das
wahlergebnis ausgerufen was passiert da
gerade innerhalb der tramp family
ja man sieht dass es daran
unterschiedliche kraftverhältnisse gibt
auch über die familie hinaus rudy
giuliani der persönliche anwalt von
donald trump ehemalige bürgermeister von
new york zum beispiel befeuert ihn auch
er soll noch nicht aufgeben und diesen
juristischen kampf weiterführen
übrigens auch wie kriminell der
ehemalige us-botschafter in deutschland
gehört zu dem teil des teams die tram
weiter motivieren dazu kämpfen
ich würde gerne noch einen satz sagen
zum thema senat ich habe dann etwas
pessimistischere sichtweise als die
kollegen im studio bill clinton klang
vorhin an dass der damals kompromisse
schaffen konnte damals gab es ja
tatsächlich hier noch eine politische
kultur wo sich senatoren beider parteien
abends zum bier zusammensetzen
nach dem was wir hier so mitkriegen sind
diese tage vorbei da wird kaum noch
miteinander gesprochen
es gibt kaum noch parteiübergreifende
mittagessen zum beispiel und ich
befürchte er dass das so wird wie unter
obama dass die republikaner von
vorneherein eine obstruktionspolitik da
führen werden und joe biden hat soll die
erfahrung als senator aber man darf
nicht vergessen als vizepräsident war er
ja von obama auch beauftragt worden da
brücken zu bauen im senat und wir wissen
alle dass das nicht allzu gut gelungen
ist und obama weit unter seinen
möglichkeiten geblieben ist also ich
sehe das ganze ein bisschen durch dann
diese politische spaltung in der
politischen klasse die hat sich ein
bisschen die bevölkerung fortgesetzt wir
kennen ja umfragen dass sich anhänger
der demokraten nicht vorstellen könnten
anhängerinnen oder anhänger der
republikaner zu ehelichen frau was mit
nelson
was wir da jetzt erleben gerade bei
trump ist das schon ein machtkampf um
die nachfolge von donald trump könnte
sich dann möglicherweise nach den
kennedys nach den bushs gewisser weise
auch nach den clintons eine neue
politische dynastie herausbilden
also sie meinen jetzt die tram familie
eine die massiven die gründung einer
länger single an studieren in dem
zusammenhang schon ein machtkampf um die
nachfolge von donald trump gibt glaube
ich eigentlich eher nicht also die die
trump familie ist jetzt im gegensatz zur
familien wie zum beispiel den busch oder
den kennedys ist es keine familie die
irgendwie wirklich in der politik
verwurzelt gewesen wäre ja sondern ist
eine unternehmerfamilie eine
geschäftemacher familie und
angeheiratete ehefrauen also ich glaube
diese politische kultur wirklich was es
bedeutet etwas aufzubauen auch zum wohl
des landes dass ist in dieser familie
sehr wenig präsent sondern es geht eher
darum immer irgendwelche deals zu machen
die sich letztendlich für das
familienunternehmen vor allem auch
monetär positiv auswirken
in diesem sich heute gerade noch heute
zu sehen und sagen was sie an gespür was
sie angesprochen hatten zu dem thema
spaltung der gesellschaft ich glaube das
ist wirklich ein großes problem denn
donald trump ist nicht irgendwie
wirklich der auslöser dieser spaltung
sondern eher das symptom dafür diese
spaltung hat ja eigentlich in der
clinton ära schon angefangen und ist in
der obama zeit noch weiter hat sich das
aufgetan das eben eine breiter teil
dieser unteren weißen mittelschicht die
früher fest zu der demokratischen
allianz gehörte ja diese sogenannte
democratic alliance
die fühlen sich wirklich abgehängt von
einer bildungs elite und monetären elite
die ihr wohl nicht mehr wirklich am
herzen hat und wenn die demokratische
partei erfolg haben will
abgesehen von den ganzen schwierigkeiten
die die kollegen ja gerade schon sehr
richtig aufgezeigt haben im senat und im
kongress überhaupt dann müssen die
demokraten versuchen diese abgehängten
sage ich jetzt mal schichten der
bevölkerung irgendwie wieder ins boot zu
holen und reformen auf den weg zu
bringen
die mehr menschen zugang zum
bildungssystem und zu arbeitsplätzen
ermöglicht die ihnen ein wirklich
sicheres und gutes leben wieder möglich
machen
denn die realen einkommen sind ja in den
letzten 20 jahren massiv gesunken und
die soziale schere in den usa hat sich
immer weiter geöffnet auch schon unter
obama und dagegen müsste man etwas tun
wenn man das land wieder verein will ich
werde auf diesen aspekt gleich noch mal
zurückkommen
herr brok eine lieblingssätze von
deutschland ist ja ja feierten sind
gefeuert hat er früher in seinen reality
tv shows auch schon häufiger angewendet
gestern hat da aus dem mund von obama
dass der verteidigungsminister gehört
der ist nämlich gefeuert worden
auf der abschussliste sollen auch der
cia und der sp-chef stehen gefährdet
donald trump mit diesem verhalten mit
dieser personalpolitik die nationale
sicherheit der usa
ich hoffe nicht dass in dieser zeit des
übergangs der nicht ein normaler
übergang ist bisher dass daraus nicht
chinesen oder russen konsequenzen ziehen
und sagen die usa nächsten zwei monaten
handlungsunfähig einmal weil das
zusammenspiel mit folgen nachfolger
nicht passiert aber auch weil die eigene
regierung von trump lahmgelegt wird
da muss deutlich gemacht werden dass
hier nicht handlungsunfähigkeit kommt
die zu fehlhaltungen etwa die chinesen
oder da der russen oder andere an
leighton könnte
im übrigen möchte ihnen und satz zu
sagen auch mit trump ich glaube das
könnte sich erleben jeden tag den er
länger so im amt bleibt machten
unglaubwürdige macht eine rückkehr
unwahrscheinliche das ist das erste und
das zweite ist innerhalb der partei sagt
man jetzt nicht du musst weg aber die
zahl der anrufe wird weniger
es wird schweigen gesagt wohin zurecht
man schweigt das schweigen ist ein weg
gehen
in diesem politischen laufen es wird
sehr einsam und irgendwann spürt donald
trump diese einsamkeit die dann ihn sehr
belastet wird aber auch die
ausweglosigkeit der dinge sehen wird
aber ich werde nachher nochmal wenn sie
dazu kommt zu diesem punkt
das gibt der gesellschaftlichen von ganz
kurzer zeit
das passt ganz gut diese
unberechenbarkeit nicht nur was die
personalpolitik angeht es ist ja gibt ja
gewisse regelungen wie es von einem
präsidenten auf den anderen über geht da
gibt es eine institution general
services administration ermöglicht dem
team des neuen präsidenten in die
aufgabe reinzuwachsen die nehmen dann an
den sitzungen des nationalen
sicherheitsrates im kabinett in den
ministerien teil
das alles wird gerade verweigert noch
mit dem hinweis darauf hätten ja noch
gar kein endergebnis vor vier jahren hat
hillary clinton in der gleichen nacht
noch die niederlage eingeräumt
dann ging das auch für die
administration gleich los was kann denn
da
trump und seine anhänger die da zudem
stehen da noch an unheil stiften bis zum
20 januar
ja das ist wirklich in der tat
deprimierend dass diese eine frau diese
verwaltungs frau diaz information
weigelt an die gläubiger oder sein job
anhänger unterstützen
das sind so ein schlüsselpositionen und
sie bei weigelt schlüsselübergabe e mail
geld aber beiden nimmt das locker und
macht einfach weiter in andere
räumlichkeiten aber in solchen dingen
häufender das wird mir schon irritieren
und angst machen was so dass aber der
übergang wird stattfinden und man hat
bis anfang dezember zeit die die die
wahlmänner ergebnis ein kongress zu
berichten und so weiter und so fort das
wird alles stattfinden
ich glaube auch dass jeden tag und schon
isoliert ist und die
gerichtsentscheidungen gegen ihn sind
und die gerichtsentscheidungen bisher
hat er alles verloren fasst es wird
schritt für schritt klar sein dass er
keine chance im gericht hat ohne beweise
von probleme und er muss eigentlich
gehen und beiden wird aber weiter völlig
dran an dieser übergang arbeiten und wir
hoffen dass es friedlich bleibt und das
ist keine probleme gibt bis jahresende
januar
herr burkhard jung wird am monatsende 78
jahre alt sein alter spielt im wahlkampf
ja auch eine rolle sogar auch bei der
nominierung in der eigenen partei da
wurde über seine fitness über seine
körperliche stabilität diskutiert und
nachgedacht in aller öffentlichkeit ist
das im moment noch ein thema
im moment ist es kein thema was könnte
wieder eins werden falls sich sozusagen
rhetorische fehltritte häufen
im vorwahlkampf konnte ich selber
beobachten in new hampshire zum beispiel
in welch schlechter verfassung joe biden
war dann noch zu beginn des jahres
da hat ja noch nicht mal fehlerfrei vom
teleprompter ablesen können während
seine gegenkandidaten ihre standard
reden alle auswendig drauf hatten
er nennt sich selbst ja auch eine
fettnäpfchen maschine hat sich schon
mancher tollpatschigkeit gelassen das
ist eher liebenswürdig aber man merkt
ihm sein fortgeschrittenes alter
tatsächlich manchmal an jetzt in den
vergangenen wochen nicht mehr allzu sehr
vielleicht hat die aussicht auf den sieg
ihn ein wenig beflügelt aber das thema
könnte eben sehr schnell wieder
auftauchen wenn er sich da etwas
anmerken lassen könnte das verbot noch
ein problem werden er das politische
urgestein das schon sämtliche
pensionsgrenze überschritten hat und
eine jüngere sehr ehrgeizige sehr
auffällige auch sehr zungen fertige
vize-präsidentin dass diese irgendwann
mal nicht mehr stimmt ja mehr ist auch
schon aufgefallen in der nacht als joe
biden seines sieges rede gehalten hatte
hat ja zunächst kamalla harris auch eine
lange rede gehalten
was ist schon bemerkenswert fand wenn
ich mich richtig erinnere war das als
obama gewählt wurde nicht der fall da
hat joe biden als frisch gewählte vize
präsidentin nicht gesprochen in chicago
und einen satz ist mir sofort
aufgefallen den kameras sagte nämlich
sie sagte dass sie sehr gut vorbereitet
sei also sie erscheint mir schon
durchaus als vize-präsidentin in
wartestellung aber vielleicht ist das
auch ein ganz gesunder pragmatismus
denn bei einem präsidenten in diesem
alter muss man natürlich auch damit
rechnen dass irgendwann etwas passiert
das heißt ja auch immer wieder dass er
nur einer amtszeit machen möchte er hat
das selber nie so gesagt aber das ist
was man hört und da wäre natürlich kann
man daher ist dann auch eine potenzielle
nachfolgerin bei der nächsten wahl da zu
kandidieren
frau schmidt nelson kamalla harris wird
ja von ihren anhängern soll das gefühl
man nur so als lichtgestalt verehrt das
erinnern etwas an 2008 barack obama
könnten sich und wir wissen ja wie das
dann ausgegangen ist könnte es sein dass
man da viel zu hohe erwartungen in die
neue vize-präsidentin steckt von auch
von seiten ihrer anhänger die sie da auf
händen tragen ja ich glaube aber dass
die erwartungen jetzt in ihrem fall
nicht ganz so hoch gesteckt sind wie sie
damals der barack obama waren sondern
kann man daher es ist einfach aufgrund
ihrer herkunft und der person die sie
ist verkörpert sie unheimlich viele
dinge die natürlich von der
demokratischen partei auch gerne gesehen
werden sie sie verkörpert das junge das
dynamische amerika in ihrer person
stellt sie ja quasi da die vielfalt die
religiöse vielfalt die ethnische
vielfalt sie ist das erfolgreiche kind
von einwanderern von einer indischen
hinduistischen mutter die sie dann auch
als alleinerziehende frau aufgezogen hat
sie und ihre schwester der vater war ein
schwarzer einwanderer aus jamaika der
aber die familie verlassen hat als
kamala fünf jahre alt war sie selbst
identifiziert sich als schwarze
amerikanerin gehört einer christlichen
baptistenkirche in san francisco an und
hat jetzt einen weißen juden geheiratet
das sind kinder sie mit aufzieht
insofern verkörpert sie einfach auch
diese sozusagen modeln motivation
techniken motiviert spd und das stellt
für viele halt einfach einen positiven
wert dar
gleichzeitig ist es natürlich auch genau
das was viele der rechten konservativen
trump anhänger gar nicht gut finden aber
der unterschied denke ich ist das kamera
harris bekannt ist auch als eine frau
der politischen mitte
sie war ja nicht irgendwie jetzt eine
bürgerrechtsaktivisten sondern sie war
staatsanwältin in kalifornien
sie hat viele prozesse auch gehört wo
sie auf seiten der behörden der
autoritäten der polizei stand und sie
hat zwar jetzt das bag lifes meta
muthmann unterstützt und sie ist auch in
vielen anderen feldern zum beispiel in
der abtreibungsfrage sicherlich sehr
liberal vermutlich auch liberaler als
joe biden
aber ich glaube dass trotzdem jetzt
viele in der demokratischen partei sie
gar nicht als irgendwie so wahnsinnig
linksliberale lichtgestalt sehen
und nicht die hoffnung in sie
projizieren die man damals auch und da
haben sie völlig recht vergeblich auf
barack obama projiziert hat herr brok
frau waldschmidt nelson das vorhin schon
angesprochen
eine bestimmtes ein bestimmtes
lebensgefühl das die demokraten den usa
jetzt vermitteln mit ihrer politischen
führung da ist ja kamelle harris quasi
das klassische profil multikulturell
urban liberal tolerant aber das ist
diese haltung und auch was ich
finanziell gut abgesichert zu sein zur
bildungs elite zu gehören das geht ja in
vielen bereichen der usa glatt an der
lebenswirklichkeit vieler menschen
vorbei deswegen hat donald trump
möglicherweise ja auch noch so viele
stimmen auf sich vereinigt viel mehr als
2000 16 liegen die demokraten da oft
falsch in ihrer einschätzung der
gesellschaftlichen wirklichkeit der usa
denn das wird ja wichtig werden wenn in
vier jahren wieder
präsidentschaftswahlen sind ja das ist
ein bisschen wie bei black sit in in
großbritannien und auch bei uns bei afd
ich sag's mal ein beispiel deutschlands
die spd die eine partei der grundschule
und der soziologen geworden ist
repräsentiert nicht mehr den arbeit im
ruhrgebiet der die arbeit im ruhrgebiet
haben bei den letzten kommunalwahlen
nordrhein westfalen im mehr als in
anderen landesteilen afd gewählt
das heißt diese links liberalen parteien
sozialdemokratischen parteien haben
keinen zugang zu ihren klassischen wlan
deswegen ist sie einem rostgürtel
michigan und so weiter da sind hier die
die strong kohls die stärken der
demokraten immer gewesen dass haben sie
verloren weil sie diesen arbeitnehmern
nicht mehr entsprechenden ihren
vorstellungen und die arbeitnehmer die
angst vor globalisierung und
digitalisierung haben bestimmte teile
des kleinen mittelstandes die genauso
diese ängste haben und deswegen neigen
die dazu dann oftmals zur rechten
gruppierung zu geben die ihnen schutz
anbieten nationalen schutz america first
usw
diese diskussion haben wir genauso in
europa und deswegen müssen parteien der
mitte überlegen wie sie in vernünftiger
weise diese schichten der bevölkerung
die sich allein
zu fühlen wieder ansprechen können das
demokratische lager ziehen das ist
gläubigen entscheidende ansatzpunkt
diese teilung des landes unserer länder
insgesamt in frankreich ist mit le pen
das ähnlich und deswegen müssen wir uns
da sehr viel mehr sorgen machen und
diese menschen ernst nehmen
wir müssen den populismus besiegen indem
wir diese opfer des populismus wieder in
unsere diskussion mit aufnehmen
glauben sie denn dass die demokraten
diese opfer des populismus da
integrieren können die demokraten in den
usa die ja eine partei der zukunft sein
will aber viele menschen haben angst vor
der zukunft gerade an camilla herrem
scheiden sich ja offensichtlich die
geister ich habe eine umfrage sehen 51
prozent finden sie gut aber 49 prozent
lehnen sie rundheraus ab an ihr scheiden
sich auch ganz offensichtlicher die
geister einer amerikanischen
gesellschaft sind die demokraten auf dem
richtigen weg diese menschen wieder
zurückzuholen und den populisten wieder
abzujagen
ja ich meine die wahl beiden war ein
signal dass man wollte michigan
wisconsin pennsylvania zurückgewinnen
man will erfolg haben in midwest midwest
ist wo die ganze swing state sind aber
dass die demokraten georgia auch
gepunktet haben vielleicht gewonnen
haben
in arizona das ist auch erstaunlich das
überraschende ist aber ist dass die
demokraten bei den latinos so schlechter
schlecht abgeschnitten haben freude und
texas das sollte besser sein aber ja da
hatte man florida eine erklärung dafür
das sind viele exil kubaner die jungen
vielleicht auch die linke rhetorik der
demokraten manchmal abgeschreckt hat
aber es waren ja auch viele aber auch
sonstige auch arrivierte schwarze
amerikaner haben ja trump gewählt mehr
als beim genau genau warum das ist die
gute frage die demokraten müssen
lösungen finden ich habe aber vor den
war gelesen warnungen an die demokraten
im die latina ist nicht das ein völlig
selbstverständlich die werden nicht
unbedingt automatisch die diebe konnten
während die demokraten mussten aufpassen
mehr brücken zu bauen
die latinos in arizona sind anders aus
die latino in texas oder florida und die
demokraten haben das vielleicht nicht
genug unterschieden und keine ahnung
aber das ist
war diese bevölkerungsgruppe wachsen wie
verrückt in den usa den in 20 30 jahren
wird die latino seiner vier große gruppe
sein und wenn die demokraten nicht wach
sind und lösungen finden dann werden die
weiterhin probleme haben zehn zwanzig
jahren ehrenschild burkhard ahrens
vorhin schon angedeutet ist denn kanada
harris sozusagen ist dass die strategie
der demokraten sieht sozusagen als
präsidentin aufzubauen sie wäre ja nicht
die erste vizepräsidentin der
us-amerikanischen geschichte die dann
auch noch präsidentin wird also
präsident oder präsidentin
das war bei truman so das war bei bush
senior so das war bei ford so es gibt ja
schon beispiele ist das aber einige ziel
der strategie der demokraten in den usa
zum aktuellen zeitpunkt erscheint mir
das schon so sie hat jetzt die
poleposition das erstzugriffsrecht oder
die beste ausgangslage zumindest dann
für mögliche primaries in vier jahren
ich würde gerne noch ein wort sagen weil
sie vorher nach der glaubwürdigkeit von
von harrah's fragten mir ist aufgefallen
dass selbst joe biden sich bei manchen
arbeitern auch immer noch schwer tut
selbst in seinem heimatort wilmington wo
ich gerade eine ganze woche verbracht
habe und ich bin da mal durch seine
nachbarschaft gelaufen und habe mich da
zum beispiel in einem supermarkt
umgehört was man da so über ihn sagt da
konnte man sehr viel positives hören
dass er sehr freundlich sei und immer
aufgeschlossen hilfsbereit
es gab aber durchaus auch kritische
stimmen ein angestellter der
eisenbahngesellschaft zum beispiel sagte
mir dass er beiden nicht als anwalt der
arbeiter empfindet weil er eben auch in
einer millionen villa wohnt und weil er
seinem sohn hunter hier und da sehr gut
bezahlte jobs zugeschanzt hat also er
hat nicht in allen teilen sozusagen der
arbeiterschaft da den rückhalt den die
demokraten eigentlich gerade brauchen
kann man sagen dass diese propaganda die
ja genau diese methoden und diese fakten
aufgegriffen hat dass die da durchaus
verfangen hat ja das fällt mir immer
wieder auf wenn ich hier im land
unterwegs bin auch drei reisen für
längere reportagen für den weltspiegel
oder so wenn man einfacher amerikaner
nach
ihrer meinung fragt dann hat man
manchmal das gefühl dass sie einer
gehirnwäsche unterzogen wurden auf
beiden seiten übrigens also die
demokraten geben teilweise fast im
wortlaut wieder was sie von den
kommentatoren bei msnbc oder cnn gehört
haben die republikaner plappern oft wort
genau das nach was der präsident gesagt
hat oder die kommentatoren bei fox news
und ich glaube diese medien landschaft
hier trägt eben auch zu der
polarisierung bei die sie vorhin
angesprochen haben
es gibt keinen sender so richtig
zumindest keinen massenpublikums sender
der in der mitte ist sondern viele
amerikaner schalten dass ein wo sie sich
in ihrer ohnehin bestehenden meinung
bestärkt fühlen und dadurch verstärkt
sich natürlich diese spaltung des
denkens und der aussagen immer mehr
diese spaltung wird wahrscheinlich nicht
weniger breit werten wenn dann
deutschland als privatmann auch noch ein
fernsehsender gründet was er ja
offensichtlich dann vor hat donald trump
könnte jetzt sagen frau welche mit
nelson kaum bin ich aus dem amt gewählt
kommt ein erfolgsversprechender
impfstoff gegen krohne auf den markt er
hat ja immer wieder angekündigt dass er
stünde unmittelbar bevor
das hat man dann als wahlkampf
propaganda abgetan jetzt ist das
tatsächlich so eine woche nach seiner
wahlniederlage kann es sein dass er da
auch eine neue verschwörungstheorie
entwickeln kann also er wird das
sicherlich versuchen das zu tun
beziehungsweise halt immer noch
versuchen die lorbeeren dafür jetzt
einzuheimsen das also seine großartige
förderung der forschungsinstitution in
den usa die entwicklung dieses
impfstoffs ermöglicht hat aber ich
glaube in die hauptsache ist ja einfach
und da sollte man auch jenseits aller
parteipolitik denken dass es jetzt
hoffentlich bald ein impfstoff gibt und
dann hunderttausende von menschenleben
gerettet werden können
ich wollte aber noch mal ganz kurz auf
den punkt zurück kommen den sie gerade
angesprochen haben nämlich die frage
warum wir so viel mehr schwarzer oder
auch latinos für donald trump gestimmt
haben als vor vier jahren
ich meine klar ist es trotzdem so dass
praktisch 90 prozent fast 90 prozent der
schwarzen für die demokraten bestimmt
haben aber doch deutlich mehr zehn bis
zwölf prozent statt nur acht prozent
jetzt für die republikaner und ich
glaube das ist
eine lassen die sich die demokraten sehr
zu herzen nehmen sollten die lange zeit
eigentlich immer jetzt die
afroamerikaner als wahl blog für
selbstverständlich hingenommen haben und
donald trump hat schon einige dinge auch
getan er hat die historische black
college es finanziell unterstützt er hat
bestimmte sage ich mal für unternehmer
für schwarze unternehmer neue
möglichkeiten aufgetan
und das ist durchaus gut angekommen bei
einigen aussehen und das finde ich sehr
interessant sieht man das doppelt so
viel schwarze männer jump gewählt haben
als schwarze frauen und da spielt sicher
eben auch sein macho-gehabe eine rolle
denn es gibt durchaus sag ich mal in
bestimmten teilen der der young bleibt
muss also der jungen schwarzen männer
leute dieses machismo gehabe ziemlich
gut finden und da konnte er damit auch
punkten also dies nur noch mal als
erklärung dafür warum jetzt so viele
schwarze ihn gewählt haben und auch bei
den latinos da müssen die demokraten
wirklich liefern und strategien
entwickeln die gut sind für die leute
und nicht nur die stimmen als
selbstverständlichen in manchen
bereichen glaube ich hatte sogar bei den
frauen zugelegt kann es seien immer
druck dass in den usa ähnlich wie bei
uns da die wählermilieus sich jetzt
gerade verschieben oder vielleicht sogar
schwächer werden also mehr arbeiter
werden die republikaner dafür mehr
latinos mehr schwarze die auch die
republikaner in dem sie eben nicht mehr
den demokraten so die die treue halten
auch die latinos und schwarze
differenzieren sich in erfolgreiche und
nicht erfolgreiche und brennt rampf
hoffentlich mit allen unerfreulich die
kampagne gemacht hat breitner ist
sozialismus sondern überlegen sich auf
latinos und schwarze die erfolgreich
gewesen sind
ob sie das risiko eingehen wolle so dass
auch manche sagen allerdings auch dass
jetzt dieses ein schutzschirm für trump
für vermeiden auch ist gegenüber den
linken in seiner partei das können wir
zu weit nach links gehen verlieren wir
diese leute auch bei den latinos und
schwarze und erst recht so dass das war
zwar mäßig und auch für die politik der
nächsten vier jahre beitragen kann und
man muss natürlich sehen also dass
florida ist völlig klar die latinos in
florida sind nicht gut auf die
demokratische partei zu sprechen weil
barack obama mit dem fit sondern beiden
die öffnung nach kuba gemacht hat das
sind durchweg leute die zurückwollen und
das regime in kuba beseitigen würden die
dias balazs die beiden brüder einer
packung dass man da andere ist konkurs
und diese leute verwandt mit der castro
familie das sind die führenden leute der
republikaner in florida und die sind
knallhart reich und konservativ und
würden niemals beiden unterstützen
und deswegen ist in florida seien völlig
andere situation als die latinos im
süden des landes
wir haben ja bei der nachwahl
befragungen zu unserer überraschung auch
erfahren dass in corona pandemie gar
nicht das wichtigste thema für die
wahlentscheidung was die wirtschaft nur
bei den demokratischen wählern da war
sie auch wichtig gewesen diese diese
frage wie man kroner umgeht joe biden
hat jetzt das als sein wichtigstes
erstes innenpolitisches thema bezeichnet
aber was da inzwischen schon alles
schiefgegangen ist in den usa kann der
da überhaupt noch drei mal als
krisenmanager erfolgreich sein
es gibt hoffnung das ist kann nur besser
werden aber sie haben möchte das ist
total uninteressant mit theorien jetzt
warum krone dann doch dem war nicht das
große thema war und einen york times
kolumnist thomas friedman hat
geschrieben dass die leute wohl nicht
bevormundet sein und die kunden sich ein
bisschen bevor monitors beiden immer
eine maske getragen hat seltsame
theorien darum geht ich habe auch
gedacht krone und beiden ernsthafte
versuch mit dem thema will ihnen helfen
aber entscheidenden matches swing state
workshops er vor lässige haltung mit
krone kam gut an aber
wie kann man als präsident an für corona
kämpfen und die pandemie bekämpfen wenn
ein teil der bevölkerung gar nicht
mitzieht
gute frage aber beiden hat die wichtige
äußerung gemacht herr neuen committee
gegründet er würde es ernsthaft annehmen
vielleicht kommt diese impfstoff jetzt
zugute vielleicht wird das langsam
seinen kurs gehen mit krone
man kann nur hoffen das 1 1 besser
gemanagt regierung ich meine coupé mit
deutschland deutschland hat es sehr gut
gemeistert warum war die regierung hat
eine klare linie
die leute haben das gefolgt ich glaube
das ist was eine marke gefährt hat wenn
manche governance gesagt hat tragen sie
keine maske zwar verboten in texas dass
die leute masken tragen das ist verrückt
eigentlich weil wir wissen alle wissen
dass masken eigentlich helfen
man kann nur hoffen dass präsident biden
wird das alles ein bisschen besser
kontrollieren und organisieren als die
bisherige video vielleicht nehmen die
dann in wo es auch zur kenntnis dass
dieser impfstoff in wesentlichen teilen
in mainz entwickelt worden ist ja ein us
atom man ja sein dass eine rainer kayser
in bishop die haupt entwicklung ist in
deutschland das sich zwischen diesen
bereichen einen türken stimmen die
europäisch und 300 millionen impfdosen
heute gesichert haben durch einen
vertrag jan philipp burkhardt donald
trump hat das ja schon auch vor der wahl
angekündigt sollte er verlieren dann
denkt er nicht nur an wahlbetrug oder
vermute dass es wahlbetrug gewesen ist
sondern er hat ja auch schon durchaus
missverständliche signale losgeschickt
an rechtsextremistische gruppierungen
wie die braut boys daraus hat man dann
geschlossen dass es möglicherweise zu
gewalttätigen auseinandersetzungen in
den usa kommt wenn donald trump verliert
er hat jetzt verloren zu diesen
auseinandersetzungen zu diesen
gewalttaten ist es bisher nicht gekommen
bleibt das so haben diese gruppierungen
eingesehen dass ist keine lösung oder
leben wir jetzt oder leben sie gerade in
den usa in der ruhe vor dem sturm
das ist ein bisschen schwer zu sagen
aber fakt ist dass die geschäfte hier in
washington rund um unser studio herum
und immer noch ihre schaufensterscheiben
verbreitert haben also die geben noch
keine entwarnung
man kann die wirklich durch kann kein
fenster schauen weil überall diese
bretter davor sind also es ist immer
noch so eine gewisse nervosität da ob
noch etwas passieren kann und in diesem
land ist
natürlich auch immer so würde manchmal
ausreichen dass irgendwo ein kleiner
funke entsteht also irgendeinen miliz
ist irgendwo rein oder andersrum
und das könnte dann zum flächenbrand
werden also im moment würde ich noch
nicht entwarnung geben aber es ist für
mich persönlich eine positive
überraschung dass es bis jetzt so ruhig
geblieben ist denn ich habe selber eine
reportage über diese braut die sie
gerade genannt haben gemacht habe
mehrere tage mit ihnen verbracht und die
haben mir wörtlich gesagt dass sie schon
bereit wären auch zu den waffen zu
greifen wenn sie das gefühl hätten dass
da irgendwas nicht mit rechten dingen
zugeht bei der wahl und bis jetzt ist ja
zum glück noch niemand losmarschiert
gibt es denn die militanz auch auf der
linken politischen seite vielleicht
nicht ganz so stark ausgeprägt mit ganz
so vielen waffen aber ist die auch
vorhanden
ja es gibt zum beispiel schwarze milizen
die auch durchaus bewaffnet sind das
sind aber die verstehen sich eher als
bürger während die in schwarzen
nachbarschaften unterwegs sind und gegen
rassistische polizeigewalt sozusagen
opponieren wollen und da stärke zeigen
wollen
die sind jetzt nicht so sehr nach meinem
empfinden an den wahlergebnissen
interessiert gut das werden wir genau
beobachten nicht nur das verhalten
dieser gruppierungen sondern auch was
aus diesen wahlergebnissen noch wird es
stehen ja noch einige aus und wir werden
sehen auch was es mit den klagen die
donald trump da angekündigt hat auf sich
hat ich bedanke mich bei britta
waldschmidt nelson bei jan philipp
burkhardt bei elmar brok und bei ihre
kirschbaum für die diskussion liebe
zuschauer morgen in der phoenix runde
islamismus in deutschland unterschätzte
gefahr
jetzt folgt phoenix der tag mit tobias
ufer unter anderem geht es auch um die
aktuellen entwicklungen in den usa das
in letztlich ja stündlich bleiben sie
also bei uns